autour à la politique avec la fête de
l'humanité c'est donc ce week end au
bourget et non plus à la courneuve et
certains militants sont troublés par
l'évolution récente de leur parti
fernando mal verre d'olivier tête
signe des temps pour le parti communiste
la traditionnelle fête l'humain
n'occupait plus qu'une petite partie du
parc de la courneuve vrai du beau jeu il
y a dix ans avec 600 mille entrées la
fête était une source de revenus non
négligeable
aujourd'hui seulement 150 mille
personnes sont attendues
la fête de l'humain perd de l'argent
mais elle n'est pas menacée pour
l'instant la fête est un événement qui a
etc et qui dépasse le problème du bilan
financier c'est un événement de portée
nationale cetc c'est le plus grand
rassemblement de france de ce type le
problème et pas de prendre la question
comme ça mais c'est de réussir à créer
les conditions pour que la fête
redevienne bénéficiaire comme tous les
partis le pc souffre d'une désaffection
générale pour la politique le parti de
robert hue il me semble même tiré aucun
profit de la présence de ministres
communistes au gouvernement une
stratégie de la gauche plurielle qui
trouble parfois militants ou
sympathisants
c'est ce que de la mutation de ribéry
qui vient un peu troubler l'image du
parti qui est père à la fois ci n'ont ni
tête son identité et dans son image les
débats de la rentrée autour du
référendum de la corse où des hausses de
l'essence sans pour robert hue
l'occasion de réviser l'art de la
dialectique il y faut un effet à la fois
concilier critique et solidarité
gouvernementale
nos militants ils souhaitent vraiment
une présence fort dans la gauche
plurielle une présence au gouvernement
et et en même temps que sion exigeant
dans ce gouvernement et nous sommes et
nous allons mettre encore plus dans la
prochaine période
quelles que soient les rendez vous de la
rentrée la fête de l'humain est aussi un
moment de détente
jusqu'à demain soir au parc de la
fournir